what about Cory your real-life husband
how is he in the kitchen with you I
don't like it you get out of my kitchen
oh yeah you know I'm very particular
about my recipes I worked really hard
right sure my husband he likes to come
in and behind my back he likes to add
you know extra stock a life ingredients
that's very bold very bold and so I
don't know I think he wants credit of
some sort because when we're eating at
the dinner table
he's like everybody's like wow this is
amazing this is good he's like yeah I
added some sugar in there and I'm like
okay you know yeah it's really good in
the kitchen with you too because he was
helping us out a little bit your
seven-year-olds cream you have already
gotten him interested in the green
shakes this green you know my son he
loves to be in the kitchen with me and I
love him being in the kitchen with me
you know it's just all about family and
creating memories in the kitchen because
that's how I grew up who's passing down
those recipes from generation to
generation so I'm happy he loves being
in the kitchen and speaking of family
and passing those generations your
beautiful little daughter Kyra who's
just six months old congratulations on
her health at all going that is going
incredibly well my daughter brings me so
much joy
she is my my I love my son and he's you
know incredible and I say my son is a
part of me but my daughter she's an
extension of do you know what I hear
it's my little baby girl and I just love
her so much she's sitting up now she's
even holding her bottle like she's just
incredible and Cree feels the same way
oh yes Cree I will say that Cairo will
kriyas Cairo's favorite person so when
was a beer yes when she feeds him she'll
start jumping and smiling and then when
he leaves the room she's like she's like
she starts crying and rueful so it's
it's so lovely to see them together and
just to see the love it makes me very
happy and I forget about those sleepless
nights
[Music]